this morning we're continuing our
investigative series crime without
punishment examining the rising number
of unsolved murders in the united states
the problem is getting much worse as
crime in america is spiking during the
pandemic murders rose nearly 30 percent
it's the largest jump in more than a
half century and then last year the
murder rate went up again at the same
time the number of murders that have
been solved is falling so much so that
today in america there's barely a 50 50
chance that a killer will be arrested
for taking another person's life our jim
axelrod joins us now with more jim good
morning well good morning ed
understanding why fewer and fewer
murders are being solved is difficult
it's challenging complex so that's why
we spoke with renee hall a lifelong cop
and for three years she was the chief of
police in dallas and she has a personal
story that brings home the human cost of
what an unsolved murder does to a family
i grew up
without a father who was killed in the
line of duty in a police agency in the
city of detroit
and his murder is still unsolved to this
day renee hall knows the pain of an
unsolved homicide from both sides the
daughter of a cop shot and killed on the
job when she was six months old she
became a detroit police officer herself
when she was 28. and my goal is to make
sure that no one else
has to live through that same level of
trauma
these sessions are about how we do
better 18 years later she was appointed
chief of police in dallas leading a
force of more than 3 600 sworn officers
hall told us that the pandemic
[Applause]
and then the civil unrest that followed
the murder of george floyd tore apart
the trust between her cops and the
communities they served
if this is a broken relationship how do
i go into your home when the homicide
has been committed and say that i'm
committed to you
to solve a crime
when you don't trust
me as a police officer wearing the
uniform during hall's time murders
spiked in dallas as they did across the
country but according to numbers from
the dallas police department her
detectives solved more than 70 percent
of homicides that's 20 points higher
than the national average one of the
first things my team and i did we met
and i told them i don't want to go to
any community where we have great
relationships i only want to go to those
communities where our relationships are
challenged i started there and then hall
set about broadening the diversity in
her own rank and file we went from 17 18
uh latinos hispanics in the police
department under my leadership to about
24 percent because the largest portion
of our community we're hispanic i want
to show you if you don't mind we have um
the rory norman news conference we
showed hall a press conference she held
in 2020. not only are we broken-hearted
we are angry after gunfire killed a
one-year-old named rory norman in his
own bedroom
what's that about for you
i'd gone to the hospital and saw
his body
very small body
and it was
infuriating
and this
has to stop in this city we checked with
the dallas police department and two
years later there's still been no
arrests made in the murder of rory
norman
it's disheartening
how can that be
you know
if if i had that answer
i'd be rich
there's some brokenness
in the amount of guns that are on our
streets
there's some brokenness in the
relationships between police and the
community and so what are we going to do
about it at this point it takes
work and it takes
owning
where we are flawed
fixing it
complicated problem and fixing it is a
complicated formula hall told us police
departments need more resources more
technology and greater buy-in from the
communities where there is now mistrust
and only then she says can we even think
about starting to reverse
this half-century long trend
but does she seem hope it seems you hear
that and it's like well that's not going
to happen the the thing is
what she has done or did when she was
chief of police in dallas it hasn't been
seen everywhere she began to broaden the
ranks in a way that mirrored the makeup
the diversity of the community that that
she was in charge of policing and she
had tangible numbers that would back up
that approach so part of what needs to
be done is rooted
in making sure that the folks who are
protecting the community reflect that
community are a part of that community
and is that something that can be
replicated in other cities well she says
if we're going to have any kind of
chance at restoring the trust that's
been eroded there must be you have to
yeah well this has been an incredible
series you've been doing it all week and
many of our stations shout out to
producer andy best who is really driving
the train on so much of the research the
team and of course the broad cooperation
between the cbs network and the local
cbs stations well for more on this
reporting watch crime without punishment
fighting for justice on the cbs news
stream tonight at 8 pm eastern or on
demand anytime on paramount plus or by
downloading the free cbs news app